start out knowing the last session so it
lets you have for everyone and you see
me right but I guess now your whole
surface as Microsoft and she's going to
give a talk on spatial dictionary
learners
thanks for introduction
so I'm frog today I'm going to talk
about spatial dictionary learning using
tensor factorization this is joint work
with my PhD advisor and email and kuma
so I guess there's no need to motivate
in this audience that feature learning
is the cornerstone of special learning
right so in computer vision you have
this multi-layer multi-resolution of
represents of images which are really
the key to success in in natural
language processing we're able to map
human languages such as words or even
phrases into vectors in vector spaces so
that the machines will understand what
the language is talking about ok so
what's really important in this kind of
things are really we want to find
efficient representation of data based
on some structure of the data say
sparsely or low rank representation or
grouping variances and so long so here
comes the natural question so what is
there a principled approach so that we
can have guaranteed learning of good
representations right so this seems to
be a very vague statement what do I mean
by good representation so dictionary
learning actually is a concretely
defined problem that aims to find good
set of representations so I guess all of
us where many with this linear diction
alerting program it's just we assumed
the existence of dictionary elements say
a and then the columns of the a are just
prediction elements then we posit that
the signals are generated through an
in-ear combination of dictionary
elements right so then the goal is
really to find the hidden dictionary
that's work that are common to all the
samples and to find the feature
representation for each sample
these feature representations are really
simple specific now there seems to be a
good you know problem set up but there
is a problem say in images right so look
at this example of three images so the
picture learning model would naturally
think the first and second pair of
images are closer than the first and the
third pair simply because these two
shapes are in the same location but if
you ask a human then we might based on
common sense web think the first and the
third pair are actually closer because
both of these images are just the figure
of false right so what's missing really
here is this invariant dictionary models
or invariant dictionary elements that we
are able to that humans are really good
at finding out but not necessary for
this traditional dictionary learning
model so but now let's say we tell the
Machine that look for a concise
representation you should use the ball
or and the start as the dictionary
elements but we still wanted to find the
locations of the dictionary right so
basically those will be essential for
our representations of the images to
distinguish between different images
okay so what we really want here is
actually a spatial dictionary learning
model that's able to have like shift
invariant dictionaries and location
encoded representation the convolution
model actually naturally incorporates
both of these requirements than them
formally the model assumes that the
generative model is the signal is
generated through convolution linear
combinations of convolution
through filters and activation maps so
these are the filters and these are
activation maps okay so this actually
the simplified version of one layer
collusion your lab so people usually
what would you do you do alternating
minimization sort of some gradient based
method
however usually these methods have this
non-convex landscape and you might often
time stockings for its local optimal
right so what's even worse in this case
is if you have this additional symmetry
which means the shifted version of the
filters are oftentimes also the solution
to your problem right so sometimes this
can be also computational prohibitive
cause you and it have usually iterate
over a large number of samples in each
iteration but let's take a closer look
at a model right so if actually there is
a nice thing that we observe that this
convolution between the filters and
activation map can be really formulated
it's just a multiplication of a circular
matrix of the filter multiplied with the
activation map so just to recall you
circular matrix is a square matrix whose
columns are just the filter itself and
the shifted versions of the filters ok
so just to write this summation into
vector form you get this stacked
circulant matrix multiplied with also
the stacked super-long activation vector
now this seems like okay are we done it
seems like this is just a dictionary
learning problem and we can just use
picture learning techniques but how do
we do dictionary learning right so a few
years ago Adam kuma a tall brought you
know this old and good inverse method of
moment back to our attention so
basically what they're saying is using
some conditional independence given
coefficients we're able to relate the
data moments with the model parameters
so what iswhat do I mean here say we
have a pairwise data moment correlation
matrix and then this matrix actually
can be written as this by Nene operation
over the pairwise data moments over the
hidden variable or the coefficients
right so this becomes like a court core
matrix and then these operations
in some special cases Corp core matrix
becomes just the diagonal thing then you
can have this nice eigenvalue
decomposition then you might argue okay
let's do just icon value decomposition
on this matrix and then we can get these
columns of a which are basically the
elements right the dictionary elements
but the claim is that matrix
decomposition only recovers the subspace
not the actual model you need to go one
level up and look at a triple wise data
moments I guess but why is that right a
simple idea is by looking at maybe
matrix orthogonal decomposition and we
know that there if there's no eigen
value gap then there is no unique
decomposition even for orthogonal matrix
exposition so this is an example you
have an identity matrix then the
identity matrix can be decomposed as you
know the eigenvectors ninya any rotation
of this basis vector are also going to
be an eigen vector of this identity
matrix so that's because there is no
eigenvalue gap okay
but for tensor this actually becomes
very nice which says that if you have a
sogno decomposition for a tensor then
even if you don't have I can value gap
this decomposition is going to be unique
and what's even nicer is that you can
just think about slicing the tensor and
then what's nice about the slices of the
tensor is that they can be
simultaneously diagonalisable and they
also share the same eigen vectors at the
tenth circle house and now it's based on
how you slice the tensor you can
actually get some icon value gap right
then you can uniquely identify the
eigenvectors
okay so now we know that the orthogonal
tensor decomposition is unique then what
we can do is become very simple you look
at the dictionary elements columns of a
and then you want to find the projection
such as we project these elements of our
columns of a to orthogonal basis right
so like this of course you can find many
such W's and but you can just find your
favorite one and you project data with W
now your projected triple wise on data
moments become something like that it
will have now an octagonal decomposition
for and since we said that tensor
decomposition tensor a cycle of the
apocrypha composition is unique then you
can uniquely identify these components
is red and blue and yellow ones okay of
course and you can then project it back
to the space because you did some
projection of W but you know what
projection you did you can then just to
W inverse to revert it back so so
question you're not using anything about
convolution here not yet
so we're only talking about this
dictionary learning so
that's under click subscribe so in a
nutshell what we have what we've talked
about now is you know tensor
decomposition uniquely identifies the
dictionary elements are to some
permutation as well as the picture
elements in linear independence and you
know the computation can be really
efficient if you do dimensionality
reduction or sketching techniques you
can implement this really fast in the
sense of complexity can also be quite a
reasonable but now what we really want
is extensive saying we wanted to do
spatial picture learning models right so
seems like there are some difficulties
there first if you don't consider this
circulant structure this seems very go
over complete dictionary learning
problem because the number of the
columns of the circular effect circular
matrix is greater than the data
dimension right and also as I said
before there are some additional
symmetries about the problem essentially
the shifted versions so this start blue
dots are essentially all of them are
shifted version of some filter and all
of them are global optimal this program
however we do observe some nice
properties for the specific application
is this circulant matrix is actually a
simultaneous diagonal group what do I
mean by that so for any same sized
circular matrix they can be
simultaneously diagnosed by Fourier
transform matrix and you know exactly
what the form of the forward transform
matrix is and then the diagonal elements
are just the Fourier transform of those
filters so this seems to be a very nice
property that you can use in your
algorithm another observation is this
circulant projection so for any square
matrix you want to find is closest to
circulant projection or circulant matrix
and it turns out you have a closed form
illusion for that so in the interest of
time I won't go into the details but the
takeaway message is that you can just
efficiently find such a closest circular
matrix now with this in mind it seems
like suggesting us that okay you can
just do a tensor decomposition with some
sort Yulin projection right so naively
what you would do is I don't know think
about a naive loss function like just
the reconstruction error on your
cumulant or your triple wise data
moments now of course these apps are
circulant are stacked circular matrices
and this lambda is the diagonal matrix
so what you wanted to do is in practice
we know that alternating this square is
very efficient then we wanted to kind of
do this asymmetric relaxation and kind
of fix the two modes of the tensor and
update the third mode okay so if you do
that this becomes a really simple least
squares problem and we know that as long
as this gigantic matrix is foring we are
able to compute the unconstrained
solution for this problem so T is not
yet a circulant matrix but then we can
just compute them our weakness projects
them into the circulant space and in
this case is actually a block circular
stack circulant matrix okay so we know
the closed form update solution for that
that's what's the problem here the
problem is that like as I said before
there is this pseudo inverse over this
gigantic matrix and if we do it naively
actually it will take o n to the sixth
time and is the filter length right so
not only it is very computationally
expensive but also you might end up
getting a lot of instability doing this
gigantic matrix inversion okay
so note that as I said before you know
these circular matrices have this very
nice simultaneous diagnosable of proper
then we can just use them to drastically
reduce the complexity of the algorithm
so I'm not going into the details of
this but essentially what we need to do
is just a bunch of f of T some matrix
multiplication and inverse of some
diagonal matrices which is which are all
very cheap some operations so if we do
that then we can get a very nice running
time if we utilize the degree of
parallelism in this algorithm
essentially the running time is just
logarithm in the filter filter length
and the number of filters oh okay so I
also wanted to compare with the
alternating minimization about the
running time so the first row is this
time per iteration if there is no
parallelism and you can see that tensor
method seems to work pretty good when
the number of samples is large there is
a lot of samples but now if you fully
utilize your computation power and you
know you exploit the maximum degree of
parallelism then the running time for
tensor per iteration seems to be better
than the alternating minimization even
if you do still have to go to make
alternating minimization which is n
equal to 0 or n equal to what sorry ok
so some set experiment results so we
kind of can you know cuz there's a
generative model underneath we can do
some cell experiments you know you can
just have your grant use filters and you
can just generate your data based on
your spatial dictionary learning model
and what you can do is to compute you
know for tensors mass of the results
from the tensor decomposition the
results from the alternative
minimization and trying to compare the
reconstruct
Nerra of the signal and also directly
compute errors between soldiers right in
this case there are two filters and you
can see the total lines are just 4 a.m.
and the solid lines for convolutional
cancer since ike we're doing better in
terms of both the reconstruction error
and the direct error on filters okay so
also you can think about the running
time these two blocks suggest that this
cancer method skills much better when
you increase the number of filters and
you increase the number of samples right
so so alternating minimization what I
really mean is like just do gradient
like alternate between the filter and
the activation maps for each sample so
you didn't have to like kind of
calculate that for all the samples right
so in summary what I talked a little bit
about method moments for learning
dictionary elements you know so there
are some guarantees for uniquely
identification of the dictionary
elements and therefore you're guaranteed
to learn a good representation of the
data also we talked about how to deal
with in variances in dictionary models
right and also how can we do it
efficiently using enough time and maybe
make the algorithm more robust and
looking into the future
and thinking about some extending this
framework into broader families of the
invariants say rotational variances
skinning variances which are common in
images right and also I'm interested and
this is undergoing work interesting
analyzing the optimization landscape of
this problem for invariant models using
tensor Messer's hopefully this will help
us to understand convolution neural Nets
better at least shallow convolutional
neural Nets better so that concludes my
talk I'll be happy to you know take some
questions
Thanks it looks like not nice I'm not
sure then that they give a convergence
loaf or robot how that they were revised
down relies on your initialization and
are you talking about alternating
minimization or so so so we're kind of
using alternating minimization as the
baseline and you know because this
problem is essentially saying you you
can just naively minimize some
reconstruction error directly on the
signal then this program becomes non
convex and of course nobody knows what
happens under the situation's what is
the optimization landscape look like can
you guaranteed to local optimal can you
guarantee to converge to local of the
point
they're your saddle points are manifold
or they are separable these kind of
things are not known yet especially
under the convolutional model and also
the tensors we still we still don't have
a theoretical guarantee that were
converge to a global optimal yet either
but based on some previous works on
cancers we kind of have some kind of you
know have some ideas that this might
work in this situation and we're still
working on things because what makes
this really hard is you know this on
Fourier transforms actually are complex
numbers right so you have to analyze
this landscape actually in a complex
space not only on the real space maybe
to stand for one more question you can
set up three available yeah that's a
very good point
no we haven't tried that so but that's a
very interesting question yes how did
you enjoy for tensors so are you certain
also I know we just do some bunch of
random initialization to pick the best
one
oh not with samples no but doesn't be
the mourner yeah I guess this in that
experiment we're not like trying very
hard to make automating minimization
work very well as like people do in
neural network we're just trying to see
essentially well one one point is we
wanted to compare the running time and
other point is just that we're not
tuning the tensor versus very hard and
we're also not tuning the oscillating
minimization very hard can we see can we
see like whether the root constructions
have held that how does the
reconstruction error compare I think
with the same
the standard initialization would be
using town I mean at least like a
stranger oh I think I think that's for
ALS right for ALS you kind of use like a
SVD kind of choice just some random
sounds okay yeah so I didn't try that
but that's a good point
and I wanted to try that okay let's
thank the speaker again
[Applause]